your fork your fans love ahead
they're still on them you guys have
taken it personal coming we just love
their facility and stole their EMP other
than your doctor's cold finger I say
it's about as personal as that you get
these - faith - so you just don't keep
that to yourself
just follow my lead okay huh dropper
bomb do it down
get to it
Valona you guys have taken it personal
here we are on our Berlin set here on
pathways and this is where Tom and his
team have stolen the EMP and they're
being chased by the bad guys
- bass - what's play - wrecking ball
sequence which is the idea of how it
sounds
it's really cool to us I even read it on
the page I'm like how do you reckon ball
to smash through a bunch of cars like
this you dream it the best crew in the
earth they'll make it happen
first thing we did was build a steel
ball we built the entire thing out of
one-inch steel plate came in at 32,000
pounds Dave does account that's three to
one split rounds away be able to weigh
to this huge enormous bog going by you
holy there was nothing left of these
cars they hit you got the ball going 40
you got the cars going 40 and the ball
ball in
grows cars in the air parks wheels
everything else
it is definitely par for the course
professor curious how we do it
[Music]
you